manifestantes tomaron las calles de
rehén
para ellos la firma de la ley de reforma
de las pensiones No cambia nada no nos
rendiremos porque aunque el movimiento
sea cada vez más pequeño es importante
no Rendirse y demostrar que seguimos
aquí
es casi el fin del mundo de macron lo
que significa que no va a hacer nada en
los próximos cuatro años va a fracasar
siempre que intente hacer algo entonces
qué es lo siguiente para el movimiento
los sindicatos ferroviarios ya han
planeado no huelga para el próximo
jueves tenemos que desempeñar nuestro
papel pasar a la acción y ser receptivos
no esperar al día del trabajo Seremos
una de las locomotoras el sindicato cgt
ha anunciado dos fechas importantes para
las huelgas el jueves 20 de abril y el
Viernes 28 de abril antes de las masivas
protestas por el día del trabajador el
primero de mayo un tono muy diferente en
la reunión del Consejo Nacional del
partido de macrón
Los partidarios del presidente quieren
pasar página rápidamente a la reforma de
las pensiones
ahora tenemos que avanzar y seguir
centrándonos en el empleo que es
realmente esencial
todavía tenemos cuatro años por delante
con macron como presidente tenemos que
aprovechar el periodo para reavivar el
diálogo en su discurso de clausura la
primera ministra confirmó su
determinación de acelerar su agenda de
reformas para garantizar el servicio de
salud para todos para el poder
adquisitivo de los ciudadanos para
luchar contra el cambio climático para
la seguridad de nuestras calles para la
igualdad de género los ciudadanos
franceses no esperan una respuesta de la
derecha o de la izquierda sino que
quieren respuestas rápidas
macron pronunciará un discurso en
horario de Máximo audiencia El lunes por
la noche en lo que según el palacio del
Eliseo es una medida para aliviar las
tensiones tras tres meses de intensas
protestas contra su gobierno